d'accord il ya du affaires conclues à un
shérif a dû à faire conclut et
j'aimerais qu'on aille sur scène parce
que les chroniqueurs ont ramené des
objets alors vous c'est quoi donc un
minitel première génération minitel 1 on
est dans les années
si tu avoir l'air d'un expert et campe
ici merci merci
et ben voilà il offrait son mac lesggy
oui le fait 180 x 1981-1983 première
génération minitel effectivement vous en
attendez entre 5000 et 10000 euros non
non non je pense non alors qu'il était
chaud combien coûtera je pense que ça
vaut plus de 100 euros santoro fabrice
est ce qu'il fonctionne alors il
fonctionne parfaitement bien les
fonctions prises il ya même le président
téléphone il est la prise électrique
très bien et il fonctionne alors il sert
à rien puisque maintenant il ya plus de
réseau oui tout ça c'est que vous
qu'est-ce que je la kiffe salaces away
est les professionnels jusqu'au bout
j'ai même gardé un be bop
ça me plaît aujourd'hui mais que c'est
assez exceptionnel combattu mais
l'accord 2 euros 2 euros
combien julien c'est super has been
comme mais c'est passé has been pour
voleurs de l'argent grâce à passer comme
nous 5e romanesque est ce salon est ce
que tu le costume ou serait un bon tiger
on peut faire un truc ça reste
militaires tuent des ceintures ou pas tu
gardes et comme celui de la prod avec
plaisir
[Rires]
non mais ça va pas faire tout le monde
sait très bien
alors au début se fige voulait vendre
moi ça c'est à toi symphonique et merde
mais je ne le vends pas qu'elle adore ça
moi je ne vends pas je le garde commence
par faire une scène alors en revanche
sans rire c'est collector c'est une des
dernières d'une série limitée il y en a
plus c'était la star d'nrj12 en
l'occurrence c'était moi les dédicaces
et c'était juste après ou pour la petite
histoire vous avez tiré à 100 donc les
pour les fans de lanmeur dirais oui
c'est la dernière et c'est également la
dernière avec cette couleur que j'avais
été me briand misandres est que plus au
jour magnifique lui en offre 10 euros
pour nos excuses pour cet hiver mais
sort du lot et au web et hard nrj 12 on
ne sait pas été sa vie amoureuse
c'est toi je pense que j'ai eu l'argent
tu peut en offrir un peu plus surtout si
bien que libre et chez toi alors 20
euros 20 euros 20 euros c'est pas mal
mais c'est pas au prix auquel je voulais
le vendre à ce que vous pourriez faire
un effort n'attendiez combien j'en
attendais 100 euros peut-être me sens
heureux quoi quoi t'as vu ce que j'ai
fait j'ai fait toute la chaîne on est
monté à 2.8 d'aider la coupe
55 max mécénat septembre est fait pour
ça mais pousse l'euro mais qu'est ce que
tu m'emmerdes 60 euros soixante d'années
qui était prêt et quand même toutes les
données c'est c'est l'animateur de ou 60
à 80 je cède je prends ces bons 82 81 81
2 puis 4 euros moi je trouve un de mes
lima 14 heures les médecins combler à 82
roublard alésien racing attendait à toni
82 euros pour la photo de delormeau oui
mais non non c'est pas la cgc de jeu
salué le soutien et la photo mais ça
vaut que dal
c'est la faute on commet un faux 82 chez
toi 0 à laisser l'avion décoller 700 000
donne raison
c'est une petite statuette comment on
avait remarqué tommy c'est que j'aime
bien le 19e siècle m'avait offert au
tout début de notre mariage ou qu'ils
avaient dû casser sa tirelire donc si ça
se trouve d'après vos têtes il s'est
fait avoir et donc ça serait presque un
nouvel abs av arias à plusieurs
centaines d'euros
c'est à dire plusieurs centaines comme
un genre de 700 mille cinq cents à votre
mari s'est pas peur
non sire front là ouais à la séquence
esther si la payant c'est le ter ou peu
après il nous dit poussé by sap les
miliciens d'auray quoi maximum entre 60
et 80 euros au maximum mais maxime et
amélie aurait commencé entrés légalement
leurs actifs d'accord ouais vous le
vendez à 80 noms qu'ils aillent se faire
voir
[Applaudissements]
heureusement quand l'un des vendeurs
puissent apparaître
elle va pas elle ne veut pas jouer
devant verser
merci d'avoir été avec nous pierre jean
et julien merci d'avoir été des maisons